here in the kitchen i'm with my culinary
partner in crime and my dearest friend
chef laura valdez
and when i say culinary partner in crime
this is our new
turns out it's new york times bestseller
thank gosh so our cookbook rebel
homemaker
we have a recipe in here that is very
near and dear to my heart this is the
squash graten
with a cashew cream
and one of the things that i love most
about this pillar is because i think
that those beautiful hearty creamy
you know fulfilling sides are such a big
part of like holiday absolutely dinner
planning
and this is such a healthy approach
there's so many recipes in here that we
swap out little different ingredients so
that you're really getting something
delicious but it's really healthy and we
kind of sneak it in there and you never
know the difference
so from this page we are going to show
you how you can make this too for your
christmas dinner or really any time of
the year so let's get cooking squash
gratin here we go so first step drew is
we're going to make the cashew cream so
it's basically vegan and all you have to
do is soak the raw cashews how long do
you soak them for if you do hot water
you soak them in hot water you can
actually get away with just one hour but
you can also just stick them in the
fridge overnight yep and it's totally
fine so these are the soaked cashews and
we're going to pour in
a little bit of water one cup of water
and then
some dijon
because this dish it has the cream it
has almond milk it has these beautiful
caramelized onions so it tends to go it
can go a little sweet so the dijon is
going to cut through that really nicely
also if you're like a cooking show
fanatic like i am here's some apple
cider vinegar you can always hear judges
talking about i need a little bit of
that acid
so this is a perfect balancer for that
and then you put in the miso next and
the miso is just gonna sort of round it
out give that umami and salt it's really
really it just brings the dish to a
whole other level all right so we're
gonna blend that up here we go
i mean
my blender
all right that feels really good yeah as
we were doing that
and this is our beautiful blender and i
will tell you it rivals the best of the
best i'm so proud of it because that
blender has really got to function for
you
okay
swap out my cashew cream here absolutely
so we've got some red onion sauteing and
they have some sage
and some thyme and i like to add a lot
of black pepper and then basically what
you're gonna do is put in a little bit
of chopped thyme
a little bit of nutmeg
you can actually try it with cinnamon
cinnamon and nutmeg those warm spices
are really great with the squashes
which is what we're using today so
you're gonna saute that until it gets
nice caramelized and all those flavors
start to sting but not brown definitely
not um not definitely not burnt you want
them to get like soft and caramely
and then all you have to do is just turn
off the heat
and actually um like whisk in or stir in
your almond milk
and i just whisked in my cashew cream as
well which is what we just pureed
earlier and so these are these are if
you've not seen them before these are
what the delicata squash looks like and
you literally just slice them up into
rings and they make a beautiful side
dish in almost any preparation and so
easy and you don't have to peel them so
what i'm gonna do actually is gonna
start building the dish so you have your
sauce
all ready to go and i'm gonna use this
guy i think and what you're gonna do is
basically pour in a little bit of that
sauce into the bottom
of your dish
and then you're going to take these
slices of delicata
you're basically going to shingle them
kind of like a roof you know
a little bit overlapping
in this beautiful manner
so i'm going to continue layering but
actually drew you have a almost finished
casserole over there if you want to do
the last layers and then we can just pop
that in the oven i do and it's going to
be good to go
so you want to finish with the cream
sauce on top yep
and get it kind of into those edges
because what we're going to do drew is
basically um
bake it until the squash is fully cooked
and fully tender but not mushy so that's
going to be about 40 minutes so we're
going to pop that in the oven
uh 400 degrees for
about 40 minutes 440 minutes until the
squash is tender
and i'm gonna grab this guy he's far
oh that's beautiful
yeah
also
one thing
that for me always changes the face of a
dish and it's what restaurants do and
that's what separates a home cook from a
professional chef it's as simple as a
garnish
crispy sage
so all you do is basically take like a
tablespoon of olive oil drop the sage
leaf in and it's gonna sort of sputter
and frizzle for like 30 seconds pull it
out paper towel salt it
and you use that as your garnish and it
gives this wonderful aroma a nice little
crisp texture
and there you have it i'm so proud of
this dish
it's one of the many recipes in our
cookbook that we're so excited to have
developed and share with you
i'm dig
[Applause]
it's so good
you know i just want to eat right out of
the bowl
go
to be proper in times like this
because my true self just wants to
motorboat right there inside the bowl i
love you love you happy holidays happy
holidays
like
why is it that when food is so good it
makes me mad
[Applause]
when food is so good it just makes me
straight up mad and i guess that's why
we called it rebel homemaker
because
we all want to be
not perfect
i think that's the name of the game
right now let's not pretend
let's not encourage that in each other
let's just be the unique individuals
that each one of us are
and to want to be a homemaker
is to make a space that gives you that
mental wellness something that you know
going out and working so hard for there
is the payoff and if you want to bring
people into that home and be an
entertainer and include them in that
privilege what a wonderful way to live
so let's all be rebel homemakers
[Applause]
[Music]